[Music]
I enjoy the same one here now you're
gonna pay from now we're forcing to use
high demand that's why we call out you
guys have been messaging me about Tom
Hardy venom all morning so let's freak
out about this I'll try to explain
what's going on with spider-man
homecoming the Avengers films and how
that all fits together there's totally a
new round of the spider-man giveaways
for the action figures all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so the best
possible thing that could have happened
they got a great actor they got Bane to
play venom it is going to be hard core
so the biggest question I know is what
is this going to have to do with the MCU
spider-man homecoming is Tom Hall I'm
going to be involved with this so right
off the bat nobody believes that this
movie is going to be in the MCU just
because it's supposed to be rated R it
sounds like Sony's treating it is their
version of Deadpool just a really
hardcore spin on a hardcore character so
that they don't have to do it pg-13 if
they don't want to the movie this is the
crazy thing so they just announced Tom
Hardy obviously we have spider-man
homecoming coming out in less than a
couple months but they've been so quiet
about this venom movie and they have a
release date that's currently listed on
IMDB is October 5th of next year so that
is a quick turnaround so the news
release about this called it a tentpole
film because it's a spider-man franchise
film there's not going to be any small
spider-man films but you know how
Deadpool was a smaller movie the budget
was much smaller than a normal x-men
movie it sounds like that's what's going
to happen with the venom movie so it'll
be smaller in scale but it'll be just as
crazy but because there's probably not a
billion characters in it they'll be able
to turn it around a little bit faster
but just do not be surprised if they
don't hit that October 5th release date
because now that Tom Hardy's attached
like he's a big name they might go
through some script rewrites and we
don't know what the story is going to be
so look at Tom Hardy's age he's very
clearly much much older than Tom
Hollands version of spider-man and
everybody knows the symbiote saga
spider-man got the symbiote during
Secret Wars came back
it started to poison his mind he got rid
of it it found Eddie Brock and then the
rest was history we got to the carnage
character obviously much more
appropriate for the venom movie than he
would be in a spider-man MCU movie
that's going to be more pg-13 so have
you ever wanted to see carnage in a
spider-man movie venom is your best
choice but they haven't announced to the
villainess they've just announced that
Tom Hardy's attached the director is
going to be the guy who did the zombie
land movie but that's all they've said
about it so far we don't know about any
of the other cast what I'm expecting
right now bare minimum because you have
to include spider-man in some way in
event a movie to explain how you got
there now you can just do a venom movie
where he's already venom it doesn't have
to be a linear timeline if you tried to
figure out where Deadpool fits in the
x-men continuity it'd be kind of hard
you could guess and say it's some time
before x-men apocalypse but there's
nothing in that movie to tell you
exactly what date it is when all these
events are happening so it'll probably
be the same thing with the venom movie
we're just very ambiguous about where it
fits in the timeline the opening title
sequence will probably tell you
everything you need to know about the
symbiote saga how he became venom or we
might see a version of the origin story
for Eddie Brock where it just picks up
when he's first becoming the character
so there's all kinds of ways to do the
movie with spider-man without having to
have Tom Holland be a huge part of it
but he did sound excited when people
were asking me questions about it but
the problem is is that he's attached to
so many Marvel movies he has both of the
Avengers movies that they're still
filming right now he has the next
spider-man homecoming sequel so he is
booked solid for the next couple years
but the really cool thing he's a totally
cool dude he said that he is down to be
spider-man
for like 10 plus years so we're talking
all kinds of other movies beyond what
Marvel and Sony have already planned so
far the last MCU spider-man movie they
have planned right now is the second
spider-man Home Coming movie that's
coming right after the fourth Avengers
film so this is the MCU timeline right
now in like early phase four you have
the fourth Avengers film spider-man
homecoming two in now guardians of the
galaxy three so when the way that Fox is
doing a bunch of different types of
x-men movies that don't necessarily have
to connect to the main ones sony's doing
the same thing - so that's where venom
fits
and venom is very different from the
Deadpool character but the way the
Deadpool movie fits in with the other
x-men movies is how this venom movie is
probably going to work if Tom Hollands
going to be spider-man for the next 10
years and I totally hope that it works
out that way then you'll probably see
him show up with venom in some kind of
spin-off way but I think for right now
it's going to be spider-man adjacent so
they'll reference things Deadpool makes
a lot of jokes about the x-men the
x-mansion which Xavier McAvoy or Stewart
now venom doesn't make jokes like that
but it's just a way for them to tie it
to the larger x-men film so just expect
the same type of treatment for venom
they haven't said which story they're
going with but they could do sinister
spider-man Bertha venom maximum carnage
although that sounds like something that
they would work up to like they would do
venom and then they would do the origin
of carnage then they would do
venom versus carnage but there's a new
ongoing venom comic book they just
brought Eddie Brock back in the comics
if you know Marvel has the big
generations event coming up Marvel
legacy I don't know how venom is going
to be tied to that but they're basically
bringing back all the core characters
you don't get more core venom than Eddie
Brock just expect them to take some of
his seminal runs mixed up with the
origin story and write something
original they never do the exact comic
book story so you'll see the birth of
venom which means there might be like a
pre credits sequence where you see
spider-man losing it him getting it and
then they go on to whatever the
adventure the movie is going to be but
let me know in the comments how do you
want them to fit in the venom origin
story with the spider-man movies if they
have Tom Holland in they don't want to
completely confuse people the easiest
way to address that is with the Zack
Snyder pre credits sequence you do like
a short film where you tell the story of
how spider-man got the symbiote got rid
of the symbiote and then it found venom
and then you just pick up right there or
if they really want to go in for it they
could actually have somebody in a
spider-man mask and Tom Holland do the
voice without ever having him take it
off but I feel like they're going to try
and avoid putting spider-man in the
movie where he's not played by Tom
Holland so they have to find a way
around that so either there's going to
be a little bit of spider-man and it'll
be a silent film at the beginning so
they won't have to address why it
doesn't sound like Tom Hall or there'll
be an Anthony Hopkins
voiceover where they tell the origin and
then you pick up last great war and we
would go the other world returned home
to the realm eternal house god but I do
think it's interesting that Tom Holland
said that he was interested in the venom
movie that doesn't mean that he's gonna
be in it I think when other people were
asking Tom Holland about the movie
earlier he was taken aback a little bit
and was like yeah if you know venom I
would be totally happy I haven't read
that script yet I think he's definitely
going to read it now that Tom Hardy's
attached to it but that doesn't actually
guarantee that he's going to be in it
because that's a discussion that you
have to have with Marvel you have to
have that with Sony and they're just so
many cooks in that kitchen it was so
difficult to get MCU Spidey off the
ground that I feel like they're gonna
try and sidestep any giant landmines
and just do that Zack Snyder pre credit
sequence so let me know how do you want
them to address the origin of the
symbiote in this movie but I feel like
one thing that they have to work out is
how they make venom seem redeemable
because he's not like Deadpool he
doesn't have a good heart
he's usually been written like a pretty
big [ __ ] like Todd McFarlane's venom
wasn't nuts so they're gonna have to
bring him back just a little bit i think
they'll give Tom Hardy some of the
Liberty to find the character on its own
like it'll be a version of venom it
won't be exactly like the comics but
it'll be fantastic just because Tom
Hardy is so good as long as he doesn't
do a version of that Bane voice I think
we'll be fine
who are you it doesn't matter we are
what matters is our plan they haven't
said too much about what's going on with
that second spider-man Home Coming movie
only that they're committed to making
him a big part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe through that fourth Avengers
film but right now unless they drop some
big bombs it sounds like that fourth
Avengers film will be a version of the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline even though
that story came before the infinity war
story which is the title of the next
Avengers film so they're kind of mixing
and matching titles and storylines
thinks a nose quest for the next
Avengers film him assembling the gems
putting the gauntlet together and then
the fourth Avengers film is the story of
what he does once he assembles the
gauntlet so there going to be some
liberal changes for spider-man story
because he's a relatively background
play
and even though you see funny panels
like this spider-man himself didn't
interact with a nose too much when he
wasn't with the other Avengers like
there's not a big spider-man story to be
told in there so the MCU version of this
is going to be a little bit different
based on the cast and the characters
that they have because obviously like
Galactus was a big part of the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline he is nowhere to be
seen in the MCU right now so if you want
to get ready for the venom movie and you
haven't read any comics before I
recommend you start with his origin like
the original venom story and then you
can just start with the new run the
story where Eddie Brock came back
because there's been a bunch of
different versions of the character the
one that was with guardians of the
galaxy was Flash Thompson who's actually
this character in spider-man homecoming
there is no way that he is ever going to
get a version of the symbiote in the MCU
it just does not look like it's going to
happen so let me know what do you guys
think about all this I know everybody
wants to see venom in the MCU but I'm
not expecting that to happen but that
doesn't mean that it won't connect in a
Deadpool x-men type way but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner jaws 7 please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details what's going to
happen next is a whole bunch more
footage drop for the finales that are
coming next week so I'll try and post
those trailers as quick as possible
while you wait for that you can click
here for my injustice to review video
and you can click here for brand new
spider-man homecoming thank you so much
for watching
high five I'll see you guys tonight